- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here and welcome
to Middle School Physics.
I have Iman Howard, who manages
all of our STEM content.
Iman, why should folks be excited
about Middle School Physics?
- So, Middle School Physics is like
the only science out there
that explains how things happen.
And so basically,
everything's made of matter.
Me, you,
the chair that I'm sitting on.
And this course is gonna
explore how we exist
in the natural world.
So, for example,
we talk a little bit
about movement in forces.
And we learn that everything,
everything that we have a collision with
has this equal but opposite
force that's applied
when the collision happens.
So, that's why when you
give those high fives
and then your hand starts stinging,
it's because the same
force you gave your buddy
is the same force they gave you back.
And then we also talk about force
in a way where it doesn't touch you.
So, like I'm thinking like Star Wars,
there's like this force
energy, like gravitational.
There's magnetic energy,
there's electric energy.
And then finally,
we get into waves.
And we talk a little bit about
how waves, you know, exists.
Whether it's sound waves
or even the waves in the ocean.
What do you think's exciting about it?
- Oh, well,
that's a dangerous question to ask me.
I wanted to be a physicist
and I still aspire to be it.
Because, you know,
we kind of wake up in this cosmos.
And we're just trying to understand what,
where we fit in.
And physics asks the most
fundamental questions
about how the universe works.
And so when I first learned
about Newton's laws,
and fields, and
all of the things that
you just touched on,
it started to give me goose bumps.
Because I'm like, wow,
we can finally understand how
the universe fits together
and then use that to make predictions.
And then think about things
that we don't understand.
And there is so much
So I think this is the beginning of a very
very exciting journey in physics.
- I agree, Sal.
(energetic blipping)